new topic new ish topic you guys know
how much I love words and how much I
think everyone should love was and how
much when you understand words you
understand things better rather than
thinking oh this is a new thing it's
called this who knows why it's called
that okay so before I give you this
heading I'm going to give you a series
of words I got one two three then you
know the meanings of but will shed light
on what we're about to do so first what
if I say things have a connection right
a connection what does that mean if
things are connected together yeah
Rachel they join together very good they
are not separate but they are they're
going to be joined in somewhere okay
perfect great if I say rather than
things which have a connection if
they'll say a group of people have a
consensus right can you come to a
consensus what would that be yeah that's
right that's right um
you agree on to say this you have a
similar kind of opinion right I would
say a way of saying that is you're
thinking together you're not thinking in
ways that like disagree and on a pot if
they get together on the same kind of
same kind of wavelength it's like I'm on
the same page connection consensus
hopefully third one oh that's right if
you have a conference of people by a
conference the whole idea is not joining
to you but I'm not making together but
I'd say you're moving brain meat or to
contribute together but the whole point
is that you've got the people and
they're you know they're going to have a
common space might never be electronic
but you know they're meeting together in
some kind of way
so therefore seeing these words and what
they mean
here comes our heading but I'm gonna
write down
what does it mean to say things are
congruent as you say things out hunger
no just before we jump in without
mathematical special definition right
you can see we have the same prefix
happening again and again and again and
you can see what it means every single
time so what might say congruent
actually okay so in mathematics we're
gonna talk about shapes and I've got a
whole bunch of shapes within you're
gonna draw a bunch okay but just in
general general let me give you a bit of
a hint right um we have another word
that go through this is almost identical
right doesn't get used all that awesome
I think most of you know it means which
is a congregation right or the would be
to congregate what does um what does
that mean attend ah you've had your hand
up
it's okay it's like it's in the same let
me say what I'm going to try to use this
word together right this idea of I in
fact I could sort of like gather these
together
congra it like the proper actual meeting
is to strangely enough to fall together
you're like before well let me try and
illustrate so if I take now
mathematically it's think of like a
shape so if I have a shape right some
artistic of people in the room that's a
cake right and if I have another shape
that is called ruin to that what that
means is they could fall together on the
same spot right and that would leave the
really be one on top of the other right
if you like think of it like you know
how they say square peg in a round hole
it's like well he's an art pagan
impartment oh it's all exactly the same
they could fall down and sit one on top
of another okay that's actually what's
going on here now when we talk in
mathematics we mean a little more
specifically here is Nathan sewing
thread in order for two shapes two
figures to fall together what we mean is
they have to be the same size and we
have to be the same shape so for
instance if this red that our Wu is
smaller or bigger it wouldn't be able to
exactly fall on top of the other one
right or if I like sliced off a bit
maybe took off this bottom part it also
still wouldn't fall together I need both
of these things in order for that to be
true okay so this idea what we have
figures and they're really identical
there's so identical they can fall on
top of each other and there would be
exactly the same by the way when you
have a congregation right it's when
you've got a curfew and they come
together only together in exactly the
same place just like these shapes do now
mathematically we can push on this idea
of what does it mean for something to be
the same size and to be the same shape
okay I would say what it means for this
like what makes the same there are two
particular kinds of properties are
looking to be identical
I want the corresponding size to be
equal or identical right so for instance
I've got this vertical side over here
right this one over here and I want it
to be exactly the same length as this
one if it's off even by a millimeter
they would be the same shape same size
but I don't just put the corresponding
sides those lengths to be equal there's
another feature I don't want to suggest
another feature that I want to be equal
to okay so I could talk about like
different ways of measuring so if these
things I put them on a scale I want them
to be the same way if they had believed
they were like I mean these are flat but
if it's like a box or something
I want to be able to pull the same
amount in there but but for instance I
happen to know that this box I have here
has roughly the same volume as the of
the real problems I have at home roughly
the same point now if it were exactly
the same you still wouldn't say that
this part is congruent to my boo
brothers at home unless you have really
reshaping your phones at home
what why is that a problem yeah
okay so what I was is not just the sides
or the volume but that other feature I
want is the angles so this is talking
about polygons oops
which can have all the same science but
we also want the angles connecting the
sides to also be sex so for instance
having a look at these shapes up here
right can you see you've got an angle
right here in the bottom right hand
corner you see that right if I put a
protractor to both infinities I'd like
to measure them and they'll be the same
okay it's no problem in this angle over
here is different to this angle because
those two don't correspond do you see
that but I want this a mukhiya to be the
same as that one I would want this angle
to be the same as this one because they
correspond to each other when I put them
so they fall together those sit one on
top of each other that's what we mean by
correspond